new york
i got a video i want to share to you
guys yesterday cuomo had did you guys
see that exchange with cuomo
yesterday cuomo had a big exchange
before you played i want to read this to
them but you can make it
get ready for it here's what happened
with new york new york schools shut down
indefinitely with new surge of cases let
me read that one more time to you
new york schools shut down indefinitely
with new surge of cases all students in
new york public schools will transition
to remote online learning beginning
thursday
today mayor de blasio announced
wednesday the cover 19 test positive
rate in the city
hit three percent over the past week
reaching the threshold that officials
said to determine
whether schools should be close closed
he said we must fight back the second
wave of covet 19 de blasio said
richard carranza the chancellor of new
york city department of education said
in a tweet that it was a temporary
closure
the mayor and i have been clear-eyed
since the beginning that we needed to
get students back into the classrooms as
soon as it was safe
and we carry the same urgency with us
today as we announced this temporary
closure we will get students back in
buildings as soon as we can safely
new york city public school system is
the largest in the nation serving more
than 1.1 million students according to
the new york city department of
education and this is what happened
yesterday kai press play this is the
city's decision they have an agreement
at three percent
today you said well i might have to
impose an orange zone and i might have
to close the schools which an orange
zone does
so what's going on does the city still
have the ability to close its schools
are you now taking control and saying
that you have the power to make this
decision
and for the millions of parents who want
to know are the schools going to open
tomorrow in new york city
all right first of all let's try not to
be obnoxious
and offensive in your tone
because you're a hundred percent wrong
he sounds like trump there
we announced the orange that's the
ironic law
over a month ago i don't know if you
were here
or if you were paying attention but that
has been really sounds like trump here
they're both from new york it always
said
if by the state's numbers you hit
3 percent the schools close
what's going on here is nothing that the
law hasn't said
for over a month we then had to test
out procedures if you were paying
attention
you would have known we closed the
schools in new york city two weeks ago
remember when we did an orange zone in a
red zone
in brooklyn and queens and we close
the schools don't you remember that
okay so don't you so what are you
talking about
how what are you talking about you're
now going to override
we did it already that's the law an
orange zone in a red zone follow the
facts
so confused well then you're confused
i'm confused
parents are still confused as well
they're not confused
you're confused no i think people are
confused as well
read the law and you won't be confused
apollo jimmy's question are the schools
going to be open tomorrow
the schools are open by state law
they closed right after that
new york city he knew that by the way
new york city yeah
well i don't really care what you no go
back a little bit go back
you got to hear the last seven seconds
just go back right there
tomorrow that's the question i think
jimmy's correct in asking that question
i don't think it's obnoxious at all
well i don't really care what you think
here we go
sums them up right there you know what
he wants to do to that reporter he wants
to sock that guy and deck him right in
his shoulder
yeah that's what he's getting because
that's what's up guys oh my god right in
the shower so tell me though i mean what
do you think what's going on in new york
i mean the guy's clearly frustrated as
well
he's an [ __ ] i mean i'm appalled by
that video thinks he's al pacino
you know here's the problem with newsome
and cuomo they think they're rock stars
all right they are so cocky they're so
out of control
they have so much power that they can
get away with crap like this
and what newsom's doing i can't stand
what they're doing i feel for the
parents
in new york city who now have to figure
it out once again
what they're going to do with their kids
and let me just say this kids
have been robbed of a year of their life
it's been
stolen from them 60 percent of them at
least will never be able to make up what
they lost this past year
it is a crime what he is doing going up
there with the authority that he has and
to be that cocky
and that out of touch and that auto tune
and did you hear the other big story
about him yesterday he got a pay raise
he got a huge pay raise look it up kai
mario cuomo got a huge now he's gonna
say he's gonna turn it down right
yeah right it'll come back to him
sideways like nine different ways but
i'm appalled by that he thinks he's an
entertainer he thinks he's al pacino
leaning back like he's the godfather or
something it sickens me to see what
these guys are doing
they have no repercussions whatsoever so
point counterpoint here that
literally that's exactly what trump does
so if you don't like what
if you don't like quotes the perception
of people that hate trump
that thinks that's what he does any
difference between his
own and his interaction there's no trump
has respect
i'm going to tell you what you're trying
to take off have you listened to a trump
press conference he has respect for the
reporters he answers their questions
literally living in different worlds
there there's no and i'm i'm
i'm telling someone who's saying that
his tone was wrong
again one of the things i'm able to do
is call [ __ ] on both sides
the way that he handled that reporter is
exactly what trump does no
if you don't see that then you're not
listening no the fact that you might
just be watching
america news or something like that that
doesn't show the reality of it
the reality is that's exactly how trump
treats reporters and if you don't
believe me i'm sure we can roll the tape
on every adam actually i'm just going to
be unraveling
of saying what you just said is wrong
that is not how trump
treats reporters he might hammer them in
a party out of control
have you seen him interact he answers
questions they
badger the hell out of trump for four
years you're going to find out
where he got frustrated one or two times
one but that is not
trump at all so trump is just a nice
chill guy that's the only defense that
people that hate trump have
they said you have to flip it and say oh
say the opposite of trump is what i'm
saying
which is not what the point that you're
missing right now you're failing to
understand
is this is not an anti-trump thing or a
pro
cuomo but the first direction you took
relax
i what i'm saying is they both
keyword both tom you understand what
that word means they both
treat reporters disrespectfully compared
to that but here's my point since i know
you have a
where'd you go to uh med school and all
where'd you go again here we go
the guy can't get past their emotions
you have to sound smart here we go
where what what what do you think he
should do keep everything open
just not pay zero attention to kovid i'm
asking you not to not to complain
not to criticize to give a solution it's
not my job to give a solution what's
your job to criticize what i can tell
you
damn right my point is i like to listen
to
to scientists okay and if they're
basically saying
hey you know where else they're shutting
down freaking kansas
freaking north dakota minnesota this
isn't just a new york thing
or a california these leftist liberals
they're shutting everything down they're
robbing the kids of school
coveted cases have increased they've
been there's their second wave coming i
know that we're a quote on quote
rounding the curve i don't have it's
cold weather's cold
cool second wave is coming colds are
coming
but don't make your point though i'm
curious my point is let's
it's so easy to criticize the the
and i'm being critical of his tone as
well here i'm not vouching
like i'm not vouching for cuomo yeah but
it is clearly his frustration was
they've had guidelines in place if cases
have gone from orange to red or whatever
the protocol is
he's basically getting frustrated with
the reporter saying yo bro
like this has been in place for weeks
two weeks the reporter said no three
weeks
and he's like well that's exactly what i
just said what are you talking about
here he's getting frustrated cool i'm
cool with that but there's protocol in
place
and if you reach a certain point and the
medical authorities are like
hold on freaking kovitz out of control
he's
listening to the medical authorities
here so that's my point so overall
his tone was a [ __ ] [ __ ] just like
trump
is a [ __ ] [ __ ] to reporters so i'm
calling it on both sides
yeah but to say that only cuomo is the
[ __ ] here and trump has never
disrespected a reporter
is outlandish has trump not taking
ridiculous tones
he's called media the enemy of the state
he's argued with reporters non-stop
forget about his reaction what i'm
asking you now yes what do you think
about what new york is doing
what do you think about shutting down
schools indefinitely what do you think
about that
they're doing the right thing with three
percent that now is covered showing
three percent
let's shut down the whole school is that
the right thing to do i don't think that
that school should be shut down
indefinitely
like never definitely let me let me let
me let me take it a different angle and
i'll
i'll address everything you guys just
said number one their their style cuomo
the way he speaks versus the way
trump speaks um i think trump
is a little less um steward i'm looking
for
he's a little less condescending in
interviews i think trump is a counter
puncher himself his entire life he's
been a counter puncher
but if you come in do you do a good
interview with him he's very respectful
he'll go through the whole thing with
you
and he gets hit up a million times more
than cuomo does cuomo doesn't get hit
up okay when cuomo gets hit up you just
saw the way he reacted
trump gets hit up every single flipping
day every second he's getting get up not
cuomo cohen was a hero
during coronavirus the pandemic and he
was he had the worst
city and worst state out of everybody he
had those that's where he started
out of everybody and he is a hero
they're treating him like a hero
like this is a guy democrats are
considering 2024 you know somebody that
could potentially be a future president
maybe a few months ago no no are you
going on record saying that trump does
not have contentious arguments
let me make the media let me make my
second part of the point what do
christie trump and cuomo have in common
they're all from new york they're all
from jersey
new york man that's how they talk that's
how they are i do business with people
from new york cause they tell me how it
is i
i don't mind doing business with them
but america doesn't know new york
mike pence doesn't talk like that thank
you so much kristen for that question
kamala congratulations on being the
first right so let me address the issue
when it comes to
trump would never answer something like
that neither would him right both tough
guys from new york they're from new york
i have no problem with that i'm very
comfortable with that now let's talk
about the school and stuff shutting down
let's talk about that okay
so how many teenagers do you hear dying
from coronavirus
how many people oh no actually how many
two there was two in california
is it probably the six thousand how many
teenagers have we heard dying from uh
flu now how many people have we heard
dying from uh
obesity that ends up leading to heart
attack and diabetes how many
how many people die from heart attack
how many people die from their body not
moving
how come we're not talking like you for
instance yesterday and i were talking
you were exercising
and you're going to the gym how many
times you're working out right now how
many times you're working out right now
kai
how many times you're working out right
now how many times you're working out a
week what do you do five days a week are
you four day
eric are you five there right now i'm
trying to catch up with homework but
usually four days ago how many times are
you working
how are you by the way you're how old 39
and a half okay how many times a week
your workout
three four days a week why do you work
out three four days a week
to stay healthy what does that mean what
does that mean tell me what that means
in what respect in what respect what
does it mean to stay healthy
eat well exercise why does exercise why
exercise
where are you going with this point what
i'm asking you is why exercise what's
the big deal about exercising
what's the big deal about moving your
body what's the big deal about
doing anything with moving your body why
do we move our body if we don't move our
body what happens
it gets weaker if it gets sloppy and
then what happens if we get fat and
sloppy what happens to our immune system
you get a higher risk for covid
you get a high risk for sickness period
not covet
your immune system gets weaker this has
got to be the
dumbest stupidest thing that people are
doing not realizing that if your body
doesn't flip and move
you get sick shutting down gyms is
ruining your health
people got to exercise the more you
exercise they're healthier yeah what
does this have to do with kids
everything kids go to school they move
their bodies they get in shape they do
all this other stuff they're
feeling better this is good for them
what the kids are doing they got to be
out there now you want to shut them down
for what so your point just to be clear
is
they should not shut down any schools
ever zero at all
zero at all now teachers who are above
60 years old
let them go home teachers who are 60
years old and up let them go home
now i'm not talking about teachers being
over six years old teachers who have
issues with asthma with certain issues
like that that's been documented not
all of a sudden have asthma today you
know what i'm talking about you have
documentation
hey let's let's address them in a
different way what do you mean sending
to you
question question yeah because i want to
get i want to you know school
i'm just going to go you know rapid fire
you give me your thoughts real quick
schools 100 stay open no matter what is
that what you're saying kids need
kids need to be out there yeah we're not
we're not talking enough about the
concept what about these guys
what about gyms gyms need to be open all
gyms
gyms need to be 100 open bars
i don't care about bars so bars do what
what do bars do though
bars you hang out and you talk and you
drink fine i the bars i'm indifferent
about
stay open fifty percent fifty percent is
finally so fifty percent restaurants
yeah
uh restaurants seventy five percent
fifty to seventy five i'm borrowing
restaurant to me is fifty to seventy
five percent uh
sports arenas football fields basketball
courts the whole 50
okay so there you do have restrictions
on certain things fine for now you're
saying a hundred percent
hundred percent certain thing for sure
not be open nothing nothing nothing
okay zero nothing should close this is
a little bit worse than a flu a little
bit worse than a flu pad
you want to do the math yeah let's do
that pull up as far as how many people
have ten times a amount of people have
died this year versus the flu what age
though
i'm not talking about it okay listen
school i just want to be out that's
incorrect that's an
inaccurate statement 40 000 people die
of the year of the flu 250
000 people have died no of corona way
more people die from the flu than 40 000
hold this [ __ ] up right now guys
but buddy keep going with your point
here here's my question for you
um is it there's no point this is a
question here
yeah so is it the kids that if they do
get covered well cool cool they'll be
fine but they give it to their parent or
they give it to their grandparent or
their aunt uncle that they live with
and then there's the ramifications of
that like
your your dad comes and visits you once
a month yep your kids go to school
they're fine no worries about daily
you know about tiko no worries god
forbid god forbid they pass that along
to
an elder person that comes along god
forbid they give that to your father
that's the concern that's a that's a
that's not a point that's a question is
there a concern
of that that a kid gets sick he gets the
coveted whatever whatever whatever
and they pass it along to an elder
person in the family let me let me give
you a completely different a different
point of it as well
what's the alternative for my 78 year
old dad
stay home by himself for the next two
years the hell kind of a life is that
you don't think a 78 year old is sitting
there thinking how many more years do i
have left
you don't think a 78 year old sitting
there saying which would i rather have
spent time my grandkids
or sit at home by myself looking at
these damn pictures
what do you think of 70 selfish you say
i'm 78 years old say you were 78 years
old
you got five grandkids you got four
grandkids
what are you going to do for
thanksgiving i want to say you you're 78
you got five grandkids thanksgiving is
coming up do you want to go to
thanksgiving even with the risk of
potentially getting coronavirus what do
you want to do at 78
i'm going to tell you what i'm going to
do i'm curious what you're going to do
at 78. if you're 78 and you've got i
mean look at you i'm asking you
okay you're 78 it's 30 38 years from now
39 years from now you have five
grandkids at thanksgiving christmas
you want to skip christmas with them
every thanksgiving with them my entire
life yeah and you're saying hey man for
this
one thanksgiving you should consider
maybe not traveling you wouldn't want to
see your grandkids that's not
the emotion asking you yes don't tell me
logic you
what do you want to do if i'm freaking
78 years old what do you want and i have
health issues
that's the key thing have health issues
my that's that thirteen heart attacks
okay i'd be
concerned about traveling and spending
would you rather
would you would you rather be on shut
down for the next six 12 18 months
and be in a room by yourself risk
that loneliness at 78 years old and your
brain is going a million miles an hour
overthinking everything
or would you rather say i'm going to
tell my kids
please be responsible please do certain
things when i come in i don't want to
hug my dad and i would talk when you're
coming we don't hug
so you're saying listen show up but
don't come give me a hug he says when
you come in okay so this is my point no
it's not your point
i'm asking you a question that you're
not answering okay so here we go but
we're getting i'm saying
you're saying that we're getting
somewhere i'm gonna show up i'm bringing
it to you
i ask you forget about what i'm saying
but you just said something that's
important but i'm telling your kids i'm
asking you
i'm asking for your advice you're 78
yeah
you got five grandkids yes you don't see
them every day because they live
somewhere else because the parents
decided to go somewhere else because
your daughter married a guy
who has a career in jersey who's working
out of dc who's working out of alabama
he got a job there
they want to come see you you want to go
see them you're not going to go see your
grandkids
allow me to answer yes please obviously
if i'm 70 freaking eight years old
50 years from now i would love to see my
grandkids yeah no question
okay what's more concerned for you is it
more
the concern of getting coronavirus or
the concern of you may never see your
kids again because you're seven years
old the answer is it can be both
the answer is it can be both i want to
see my grandkids clearly right i mean
who doesn't want to see their
grandchildren
but at the same time there is something
called the freaking pandemic going on
sure
so as you just said yeah maybe your kids
don't give grandma
uh grandpa kiss you said yourself that
maybe dylan doesn't get to sleep in the
same bed as his grandfather
maybe like what rules have you put in
place he shows up
does he wear a mask does he not wear i'm
asking you no listen let me give
let me give one thing that coronavirus
has done that i give
the the positive of coronavirus what is
that everyone's on the junction
here's what coronavirus has done what
chronovirus has done is the following
chronovirus has gotten me to pay
more attention to cleanliness
chronovirus has gotten me to pay closer
attention to
when the kids are sick to not go lay
down with papa
coronavirus has gotten me to be a little
bit more careful with my dad when
coronavirus first initially came guess
what
i called my dad i said dad and i told
him i said that you're not leaving the
house so what are you talking about i
said you didn't live in a house
so i'm going to leave the house and go i
said dad you're not leaving the house
we'll bring everything
i said this to my dad said you're not in
march march 11th march 12th i said
you're not leaving a house he says i'm
leaving the house my you don't tell my
dad what to do my dad's a
very strong personality by the way for
the record i love you
i know you're doing it he loves you too
he's your number one fan all right so
and and we go
and he says i'm not leaving the house i
said okay
i said i said you're not leaving the
house you know what happened i kept
checking on him every day
no i'm here do you know two months later
he lied to me do you know he started
working but he didn't want to tell me
really he didn't want to tell me so i i
caught him
and i called him we got into it you know
what he finally said to me
what the hell you want me to do stay
home yeah what do you want me to do
you want me to stay home i have nothing
to do i have to do something
i totally hear you on that i'm not
saying that he should be sheltered in
places he taught
me i don't know what it is to be 78
years old
you don't know what it is to be 78 years
old i only know what it is to be a 42
year old man in my situation
and i want to hear from a 78 year old he
says i can't stay home
if i stay home i get sick i have to go
out and do things you get sick like
emotionally mentally sick because you're
not creating anybody the most bitter
people in the world are those that don't
create
the most bitter people are the ones that
are sitting there doing nothing if you
ever find that make a list of the most
bitter people in your life
and right then what did they create
lately nothing if you don't
create anything you get bitter people
need to create things to be happy says i
need to go out and build something
that's my dad 78 years old so here's my
question because we'll i'm sure we're
gonna
have to move on a sec what is your dad
doing for thanksgiving and what room is
going to be in dallas
and what rules are you going to put in
here there's a room for himself okay
and he has a room for himself and he
hangs out with the kids
while he's there when i come in i don't
kiss him on the cheek we always kiss on
the cheek
and it's more fist bump and hey what's
up you know we go in he tells us what he
wants to do
why are you doing a kiss on the cheek
and why are you doing fist bumps because
he's comfortable with it he says you
know what it's let's uh
cover by the way he coughed in a you
cubs
yeah you know let me say this three
points i'm gonna make real quickly
number one
the shutdowns are not about covid okay
period end of discussion
number two there's a certain percentage
of people in this country that want to
save everybody
that everything has to be safe that
there's no risk at all and a lot of them
are governors
and the third thing is the shutdowns we
did in the spring didn't work
these aren't going to work either let's
just crush some more businesses
let's just take more restaurants out and
their ability to support their family
and even live let's just
let's make gym owners bear the brunt of
this how about you own a spa
or you own a nail salon oh you're you're
not allowed to be in this country
anymore and thrive and do anything
it's all a joke and it goes back to mr
cuomo and his attitude
they want to control everything about
everybody's lives for the sake
of saving everyone and that's the bottom
line so your your point is
everything should be 100 open everything
i'm not answering these questions what
are you talking about
you don't ask rational questions i'm
asking you a question tom rational
question
but you're not everything be a hundred
percent i'm not arguing for something
ask me any question i'll answer it
you're like duck all these questions the
question i'm asking you is very point
blank dude
should everything be hundred percent
open
is it i'm not a governor i don't make
these decisions
it's not enough to me i should be shut
down at least i don't
set policy i don't look at percentages
of what needs to be shut down
i give you a broad picture perspective
of reality of what's going on in this
world
for non-naive people i'm looking right
now no i'm looking right at you i
respect what you're saying i really do
but i'm asking you generally right here
looking at you what
should not be a hundred percent right
now again
this is this is veering the podcast into
a direction it doesn't need to go
that's not like we just talked about it
to talk about every single day
you just said you give your opinion so
i'm not looking for scientific facts
yeah but you just asked me for a fact
you asked me i'm asking you
in your opinion what percentage of
things should not be a hundred percent
i want to comment on the issues that
we're talking about we were talking
about new york city
bro the country's losing its mind
there's my stuff
so so everything so by based on what you
said
everything should be 100 open again this
these are not questions i'm going to
answer because what do you mean you go
again
because you're trying to back me into a
corner that i'm not even near
this is us talking here buddy forget
we're on a podcast forget it forget
about the audience next subject the
audience loves you i'm asking you
what should be not a hundred percent
this this is not
listen i'm going to help you out here
you can even just use his
notes pat said bars should be 50
restaurants 75 that's fine pat gave an
answer he didn't duck out of it
do you can just say i agree with pat i
agree those should be the numbers you
can get out of this and just say i agree
with that
by the way good mother just said the
shutdowns are exposing the people
in the wrong seats love it government
should not be moms
uh meaning shouldn't be moms like hey
i'm going to take care of you and
protect you but let's transition from
this topic here's my point bottom line
is
yeah we're here at work every single day
yep have i ever
called in that i'm in my basement today
pat you have not have i showed up
every single freaking day i never did
not leave here until 10 p.m every single
night sometimes midnight okay yeah those
are crazy i will say this church should
be 50
over okay there we go tom just answered
the question ladies and gentlemen
so if churches should be 50 percent
is that what you just said churches need
to be open they're not open in
california the churches should be 50
let me let me there we go so there's
some rules and regulations in place i
like it tom we answered it i'm proud of
you but by the way i think you guys need
to go have a drink together tom doesn't
drink i would love to drink i'd like to
get wasted but tom has never had a drink
the one day in the podcast
tom what are you drinking what are you
talking about i haven't had a drink on
the podcast what are you drinking i like
tequila and i like bourbon
yeah we had we had a one time we went to
uh chamberlain's and we got that uh
the old-fashioned we had some
old-fashioned what's phenomenal yeah
he'll have an old-fashioned and maybe
you guys can hash it out there's nothing
nice i'm asking tom a question and he's
saying that he doesn't want to answer
but he did he did answer